moi je suis prête à remonter jusqu'à
s'en sortira un régisseur chauffeur bas
qu'ailleurs mais pour quatre ans je le
fais non trois sont non gras tous je
fais le matos mais c'est mon dernier mot
on part en tournée les gars c'est
qu'elle jambon de pays
voici notre bac leider chauffeur crise
est en blanc dans un témoin sa porte pas
là j'ai pris blanc pourquoi leur père
n'a ni sa re ouais elle à la carte ou
motivés les uns ou quoi vous êtes à
peine à me lever avec votre dernier clip
temps faut pas mépriser les personnes
âgées
même mon chat qui se grattent le cul sur
son canapé tu as envie de vue
voilà là on va fumer 40 bull d'essence
pour rien on sera représentée cacher
wenner c'est câblage pour les branches
dans la trachée artère seul ou même
complètement en colère ce farine mec est
un tueur à gages [ __ ]
maintenant cette visite d'un malaise au
monde a fait 600 euros au resto c'est
quoi pourtant la notion exact on a
beaucoup de restaurants
les mains de tes plans foireux stade je
pense que tant que la peste de français
tu vois ce que c'est un salaire stable
je sais pas on voit je sais que quand on
est sur scène on est ensemble c'est le
seul moment dans ma vie où je me sens
vivante comme j'essaye toujours de
prendre le pouvoir même code sont plus
petits tous
être sont ils ont rien compris à la
musique ces trous du cul normande
sa faute à lui là c'est lui qui ne
portent l'oeil depuis le début le chat
blanc va